ein acker im wendland auf den ersten
blick nichts ungewöhnliches doch
anderthalb meter unter der erde liegen
hier hunderte keller vergraben gefüllt
mit quartz kräutern oder kuhmist sie
sollen so wörtlich kosmische kräfte
sammeln das zumindest glauben demeter
bauern
steiner beschreibt das so leer sagt die
verdauung der kuh spiegelt sich in
rohren aber ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass wenn die kuh
grast und sein futter zu sich nimmt was
er dabei dabei ein drucken sammelt ja
und er geht davon aus dass sie mut sich
eben rohren was die eindruck spiegelt
eben hohen in die verdauung und deswegen
hat man auch ein mist der irgendwie sehr
fruchtbar ist und sehr viel leben
spendet dann wird das in rohren
verkörpert und die erde und und er sagt
und es fügt sich das kosmische kraft zu
an diesen mist
demeter der älteste bio verband
deutschlands schreibt dieses ritual vor
auch der gebürtige niederländer
sebastian hofmann folgt deren
richtlinien im herbst vergräbt er auf
seinen 950 hektar ackerland rund 2000
hörner um deren inhalte im frühjahr auf
dem feld mit kuhmist vermischt zu
verteilen spirituelle geschenke so nennt
demeter die horn präparate
wissenschaftliche belege für deren
wirksamkeit gibt es nicht doch das ist
viel ruhig man nicht entscheidend
ich habe das gefühl dass die arbeit an
die präparaten und das führen des
präparats und das ausbringen dass das
sozusagen sich das hinwenden der erde
dass das eigentlich eine wirkung hat
auch das gefühl kann ein richter über
die wahrheit sein einsatz von rudolf
steiner begründer der anthroposophie
der selbsternannte hellseher meinte
zugang zu einer geheimen geistigen welt
zu haben die ihn erkenntnisse über
kosmische zusammenhänge ermöglichte er
verstand diesen glauben als wissenschaft
die sich in der praxis belegen ließe
auch in der landwirtschaft
1924 hielt er auf gut cco berits bei
breslau seine landwirtschaftlichen
vorlesungen mithilfe geistig kosmische
kräfte sollten anthroposophische bauern
ihren boden wieder fruchtbar machen
wenige jahre später gründeten sie die
mieter
es gibt letztendlich um ein esoterisches
über wissen das hat zur folge dass das
herkömmlich diskurs orientierte
wissenschaftlich erforschen und arbeiten
damit relativiert wird und dieser
geisteswissenschaft wie es rudolf
steiner bezeichnet untergeordnet wird
also das heißt eine relativierung bis
hin eben auch zu einer ganz starken
wissenschaft skepsis
gefühlte wahrheiten anstelle
evidenzbasierter wissenschaft gerade in
der pandemie sind anthroposophische
glaubenssätze in verdacht geraten
nährboden für wissenschaft skepsis zu
bieten sebastian hofmann ist zwar kein
impfgegner und dennoch relativiert er
die gefahr durch den corona virus
dass man das vielleicht auch so
durchstehen könnte aber ich kann auch
verstehen dass das gefragt ist und
erst mal völlig gesicht ist ja alle gar
freigelassen werden in ihrer
entscheidung zweitens finde ich es nicht
gut dass man dass alle menschen in eine
ecke gestellt werden ja sagen okay sind
alles gehört zuallererst radikal und so
weiter auch demeter distanziert sich
offiziell von der sogenannten querdenken
bewegungen und
verschwörungstheorien und doch träumte
das hauseigene journal in der pandemie
von einer welt ohne forschung und ohne
zerstörerische geistes eliten es handle
sich dabei um ein gedankenexperiment
nicht um eine politische agenda so
rechtfertigte sich der verband nach
öffentlicher kritik letztendlich werden
dann auch die wege geebnet auch für
verschwörungstheorien dass es eben
irgendwie mächtige eliten oder
interessensgruppen gibt hier in dieser
welt die
die heimlichen drahtzieher sind die
letztendlich auch vielleicht böse
absichten verfolgen und eben gerade
diese durch geistige von seiten der
anthroposophie verhindern möchten
die meta ein weg der erkenntnis und eine
methode um den geist der anthroposophie
in die mitte der gesellschaft zu
transportieren an diesem tag liefert
sebastian kuschmann seine karotten an
die naturkost saft uriah völkl nur
wenige kilometer entfernt
auch für unternehmenschef boris völkel
ist das unternehmensziel den demeter
gedanken zu verbreiten diese haltung die
die dynamischen landwirtschaft die eben
anthroposophisch grundlage hat
scheint mir das potenzial zu haben weil
das auch in die welt zu tragen denn die
klassischen journalismus wie
lebensmittel hergestellt werden
besonders schnell oder im großen zielen
auch ein bio die taugen nicht für eine
zukunftsfähige landwirtschaft und von
der enkel die landwirtschaft und für
eine wärme durchströmt der welt wo es
alle an der wertschöpfungskette
beteiligten gut geht in den 1920 er
jahren gründeten seine urgroßeltern im
wendland eine freie siedlung inspiriert
von rudolf steiner pflanzten sie bäume
an verarbeiteten ihr obst zu saft
[Musik]
100 jahre später macht das unternehmen
knapp 100 millionen euro umsatz im jahr
boris völker bezahlt das doppelte des
marktpreises wenn seine erzeuger nach
demeter kriterien produzieren auch er
sieht dabei gestaltende kräfte des
kosmos im hintergrund wirken
ich kann auch merken dass zum beispiel
rote beete ganz ganz
empfänglich ist für die kosten sprechen
da merkt man das einfach das ist kein
stumpfes bank glauben oder nicht oder so
über jahre das sehr kritischen hin zu
hören sind schmeckt und so weiter merkt
man dass beide das ist eine ganz
unpolitisch war rote beete merkt man das
einfach wenn das ganze konzept einfach
funktioniert und sich bei einem wahlsieg
bekömmlichen und wohlschmeckenden
produkt widerspiegelt dann spricht das
ja auch gewiss erwarten für sich ob dem
etat das bessere bio ist lässt sich
nicht belegen die anthroposophie bleibt
eine als chemie für eingeweihte doch
völkl will neue zielgruppen erreichen
2018 produzierte das unternehmen mit
attila hildmann einen dosen bio energy
drink damals galt der verschwörungs
ideologe noch als starkoch doch bereits
2015 während der flüchtlings debatte
bezeichnete hielt man politiker als
kriegstreiber
2016 behauptete er integration führe zu
deutscher selbstverstümmelung im
frühjahr 2020 beendete völkel die
zusammenarbeit
ja da war das kämpferisches für vegan
und rettet immer noch den tiger und so
das gesamtkonzept der schlüssel hat sehr
gut funktioniert und die rezepturen
waren super das war schon sehr
provokativ
aufgesetzt aber irgendwann als wir
gemerkt haben okay dass da entgleitet
was haben wir einfach gesagt okay stopp
hier geht's nicht weiter mit uns wir
können jetzt nicht jeden kunden
ideologisch irgendwie überprüfen ja aber
da war das eindeutig eine grenze
überschritten wurde haben wir dann
vielleicht doch es muss hier aber
grundsätzlich war das ein war das ein
tolles konzept also eigentlich schade
also ich finde die welt braucht bio
energy drinks mit guten fairen
rezepturen die nicht von der chemiekeule
sind
bei völkl muss nicht alles immer
rational seien dieses familien motto ist
anfällig für entscheidungen die manchmal
nur schwer nachzuvollziehen sind und
doch setzten die vier brüder prioritäten
die sie von anderen unternehmen
unterscheidet 90 prozent des gewinns
fließen ins unternehmen zurück zehn
prozent gehen an gemeinwohl orientierte
projekte
anthroposophisch inspirierter
unternehmen wie völke nehmen ihre
verantwortung ernst gerade weil
materieller erfolg nicht alles für sie
ist
wir müssen so viel einmal
wirtschaftlicher rationalität wie es
geht war weil das was sinnvoll ist für
die menschheit ist nicht immer das was
für ein unternehmen in den nächsten zwei
jahren die profitabelste lösung ist das
heißt wir dürfen nicht darauf warten
immer nur den wirtschaftlichen anreiz zu
setzen sondern wir müssen an die
intuition und sozusagen an das gute
glauben und auch daran arbeiten und als
vorbild agieren
die praxis von demeter bietet
innovatives potenzial denn sie verbindet
nachhaltigkeit mit einem ganzheitlichen
blick auf den menschen und seine umwelt
doch die esoterischen grundlagen der
anthroposophie führen uns letztlich
zurück in einen schicksalhaften kosmos
in dem am ende nicht ein rationaler
diskurs sondern höhere mächte über die
zukunft des planeten entscheiden